hallo leute ich es wieder einmal war mir
und bekommt seine mine freude wie
schmeckt und heute machen wir diesen
power diaries pancakes es klingt super
special aber eigentlich sind es nur
normale denke ich dann haben sich sehr
viele gewünscht dass ich mal gaimans
kein sex aus staffel 6 folge drei
nachmachen und bevor ich überhaupt
anfangen stellt sich mir eine frage wo
ist mir egal ich kann mir das nicht
erklären ich mein ich bin hier in berlin
und sie in köln
warum ist nämlich in der kirche mein
diese frage die lässt mich zur zeit
einfach nicht mehr los
positiv kam aber zu den wichtigen dingen
beim pay day wie ich habe viele
gemischte gefühle von dieser serie denn
einerseits liebe ich sie und
andererseits denkt niemand mal
es kann nicht jeder so verdammt hübsch
sein ist eine schippe zu viel das ist
aber leider bei amerikanischen die
sendungen so oder bei sehr viel für die
little liars na gut die müssen credit
sein weil sie sind per teenager liars
aber deswegen schauen wir uns das
wahrscheinlich auch so gerne an und ja
papiere müssen alle hübsch sein ich weiß
sonst wären zeit nicht vampir uns
während halb normale menschen mit
spritzen fit
aber warum macht damon pancakes wenn er
doch ein vampir ist und sie
bekanntermaßen nur blut trinken
nun ja es ist so dass er mit boney in
einem paralleluniversum gefallen ich
sage euch jetzt nicht wieso und was
alles dabei passiert auf jeden fall
durchleben sie jeden tag den zehnter mai
1994 dadurch die tage immer wieder holen
sieht man damon immer mal wieder
pancakes machen und sie sind auch einmal
für pancakes einkaufen und dort nehmen
sie mit milch
und ich sehe blaubeeren im einkaufswagen
und erdbeeren hatten wir wissen dass
pancakes aus mehr als milch und eiern
gemacht werden werde ich noch ein paar
zutaten hinzufügen und dann versuchen
wir mal so richtig schöne anmelden
pantex hin zu trinken also letzten
moment kaum ein wort leute ihr wisst
nicht wer gerade an der tür war der
postbote und wisst ihr was er
mitgebracht hat ein neues sky
ticketangebot end hoffen zu lesen von
vampire diaries gibt es ein neues ticket
angebot und zwar könnt ihr jetzt zwei
monate ist galt entertainment ticket und
zwei monate sky cinema ticket und neun
euro und 99 fest in der infobox findet
die den link und wenn ihr euch beeilt
dann bekommt ihr noch die restlichen
tage vom september geschenkt und könnte
bis ende november alle serien und filme
genießen und die haben natürlich nicht
nur wer paris sondern auch der walking
der supernatural und was mich persönlich
noch sehr sie erfreut vier blocks ab
oktober die neue staffel
denn wer vier blocks die erste staffel
noch nicht gesehen hat der hat was
verpasst also gut dass auf jeden fall
nach und schaut euch im auf sky
entertainment sky entertainment ticket
die zweite staffel an und bei dem sky
cinema tickle bass dazu gehört zu dem
paket kann ich euch auf jeden fall patch
3 empfehlen auch ein super für mich aber
alle drei teile gesehen und sind sie
alle
und das dritte liga und jetzt am ende
dieser reklame möchte ich sie noch
freundlich darauf hinweisen was sich die
ausgänge vorne und hinten befinden das
bedeutet dass sie das angebot auch
monatlich kündigen können sie können
sofort auf den ersten blick klicken und
los weil sie sich gerade auf den weg in
den urlaub machen sollte das kein
problem darstellen da sich sky ticket
eu-weit streamen länder schneiden sie
sich anschauen sie ihre lieblingsfilme
und serien auf tv tablet smartphone und
anderen streaming abspielenden geräten
wir wünschen ihnen eine währung ende und
jetzt machen wir das einfach sicherlich
der welt ich bin abhängig sind eine sehr
intuitive sache also wenn man mal eine
grenze nicht richtig trifft macht das
absolutes aus wir nehmer 200 gramm gehen
könnt ihr euch vorstellen einen tag
immer und immer wieder zu erleben ich
mein es hat etwas positives weil man ist
ja sozusagen unsterbliche man weiß mit
stirbt nicht
wenn man den tag davor nicht gestorben
aber war im team sind eh schon quasi
unsterblich ein teelöffel backpulver
wenn ihr gerne unsterblich wüsste gerne
habe ich unsterblich werden wollen würde
ich meine hier wird noch viel erleben
was bestimmt cool ist aber man sieht
dann halt auch alle menschen die man mag
ja und dann lernt man ja immer wieder
neue leute kennen und dann sterben die
wieder mich brauchen wir bei den milch
und eier haben sie eingekauft 150
milliliter milch zweier verlören dieser
schneebesen ist scheiße
[Musik]
definitiv zu wenig milch und deswegen
sind picknicks einfach du kannst einfach
mal nach für daten werde videos sind wir
heute nicht geizig und machen noch
vanillezucker 1 punkte von dr oetker
perfekt ein tipp für jeden tag gemacht
am besten nachdem rühren mal kurz sacken
lassen
ganz entspannt wer mag ich nicht so
schnell würde euch so ein pancake art
geo interessieren weil es haben schon so
viele jetzt gemacht aber ich hab da halt
auch voll bock drauf
die uaw ich habe ganz vergessen ein
bisschen verein zu machen und das mache
ich gerne sofort in den teig anstatt auf
die fahne
weil dann kriegst ein schöner oberfläche
und es sieht nicht so frittiert aus und
schmeckt nicht zu frittieren einmal
einführen dann lass uns mal schauen ob
die was geworden sind
[Musik]
dann wird er wahrscheinlich fahne zu
weiß ja nicht perfekt aber schon ganz
schön auch
[Musik]
müssen einmal auf jeden fall studieren
vergessen und auch schuss nicht
[Musik]
okay wer wird besser rp perfekt auf
bundesebene freunde
er ist ein richtiger märkten kein klick
du bist sonntag morgens und ich mach das
thema an dem drei gleichzeitig leute
drei gleichzeitig kundschaft wartet und
mit kurt auch mache ich mein bauch sind
fertig und sie sind fast so heißt wie
damon lass uns das mal schön hier an
richtung sotschi sind unsere blauen
heidelbeeren dann lasst uns jetzt mal
dekorieren so ein paar heidelbeeren
ich meine wenn du eine hexe bist musst
du sehr gesund essen damit deine kräfte
auch immer streckt und bei der erdbeeren
werden wir mal den strom
ich bin kein blogger leute ich weiß
nicht wie man das jetzt am besten
dekoriert apotheken ghana und ob nun
stellung natürlich bietet
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmecken die
pancakes aus vampire diaries von damon
für ponys was soll ich sagen es
frühstück der welt einfach es ist so
simpel hat es da wieder an der tür
geklingelt
ach mensch das war schon wieder der post
oder der gesagt hat denkt anders
ticketangebot erster link in der
beschreibung zwei monate cinema ticket
zwei monate entertainment drei monate
bei 9 euro
spricht er von den in der beschreibung
und dafür dass sie fleißig die werbung
geschaut habt bekommt ihr jetzt trick
chance leute mit lebensmittel steht man
die letzte ich hoffe natürlich wie immer
euch hat dir gefallen und dann ja und
zeigt dass wir unbedingt mit dem daumen
nach oben aber mit einem kanal um keine
weiteren videos zu verpassen aktiviert
die glocke um keines meiner neuen videos
zu verpassen und dann würde ich sagen
schreibt mir gerne die kommentare was
jetzt machen soll
ich hoffe das habe ich es nicht schon
mal gesagt wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal mach das jetzt den ganzen tag
[Musik]
drei sekunden regel